Hello, everybody!
My name is Markiplier,
and welcome to LEA.
Now... This is a game that was unfinished.
It was released by the developer because they said they couldn't work on it anymore or they didn't wanna work on it anymore.
And the point of this build is that supposedly even what they had was really good.
So I wanna see it for myself and if it is good I want to actively encourage the developer to do something about it.
Hello!
Ohhhhh.
'Dat mouse 'doh...
Oooooooohhh... That a lot of sensitive...
Okay.
"Lea, we had to go out and pick up a few last minute things. Feel free to head upstairs to your room.
Sorry the television isn't working."
This seems like pretty normal stuff,
why would my mom suddenly direct me to my room?
I'm not a hundred percent sure.
Man, the sensitivity on this son of a bitch is IMMENSE.
Hello! Ohhh. 'Dat nice and spooky.
Woah.
What the-
Ah-
Uhm...
Okay.
I guess that painting's just gone now!
Hello!
What about this abstract art?
What kinda' weird setup for a house is this anyway?
Hello!
Okay, byeee.
And maaaaaan this- This mouse sensitivity- Is there an option?
Oh, man- Hang on.
Let me see if there's an option for this.
Okay!
I am back a- And- Uh- Oh j- Oh go- Oh God! Oooh God
It's SOO sensitive!
Okay.
So there was no way to change it in-game and I thought I could change it by changing my se- My mouse settings manually, but no.
It's just blasted up to 11!
Hellooo?
Hello?
MOM!
You said I could come in!
Okay, maybe there's a key somewhere over here.
I just gotta' be like really, really obsceeeeeenely-
Did I see something?
Obsceeeenely gentle with it..
Oh yeah, I forgot.
Okay, so...
What happened to you?
What happ-
Ooh.
That's what happened to you.
Okay.
Ah.
So, I was supposed to get a spoop there, and I unintentionally gave myself a different spoop than the spoop I was supposed to get.
Oh.
Hello, same picture that was outside and is now fallen!
Hello, house that is creepy and low ceiling-ed!
Hello, house that is creepy and low ceilinged.
OooohzZzZzRfoh...
What do you got here?
"Don't open please!"
Why not?
Wh-Why-
Why?
Wh-Why wouldn't I open this?
Is that blood?
Why?
It doesn't make any sense,
/MOOOM./
What's that?
Lea's birthday.
Is that today?
Actually, what month is that?
It doesn't say it- November.
Woah.
Oh, I thought the- I thought IT was moving up and down for a second there.
Okay!
This is wei-
Ooh.
Okay, that's nothing.
This is weird and dark and... I can't see shit.
And my- My wrist is being strained trying to control th-
Oooohh.
Okay, nevermind!
Hi!
Who's in there?
Fuck you, I'm coming in!
Alrighty then. Fine.
Hello!
Hiiiiiiii!
Ah, good.
Oooh!
"If a tree falls in the forest and no one is around to here it, does it make a sound?"
Well, I don't know! Why don't you tell me, Mister Buddy Bear?
Ooh.
So dark.
So dork.
(creak)
Hello, bathroom!
Ah, good.
Ah, good. Yes.
Oh, that looks like a normal shower.
What is that?
Hello.
Uh-oh.
"Remember this?"
No. Not at all. No. No.
No. Not particularly, but I bet there's something standing behind me.
Oh.
Ok.
Alrighty then.
Eugh, I thought this door closed on me. Didn't it?
(gasp) Fuck off.
HI!
BYE!
Ok.
Alright, that was a good visit.
Oh, this opened up!
Oh, hello.
*sings* London bridge is falling dow--
Oh-- Teen dies af- *knocking on door*
Ok...
Hi.
Who's out there?
Is someone knocking on the front door?
Oh, I forgot to lock it didn't I?
Well, that was dumb of me.
Ah, I did. Yes.
Forgot to close that.
Huh...
Welp...
I pretty much deserve death at this point.
Uhhh-okay, Well I don't think there's any point to all these.
Just a bunch of basic stuff that a kitchen has: Booze, no food, a fridge with probably body parts in it.
The TV don't work.
Let's test that theory.
Huh, yep, that broken.
That broken alright.
Alright, time to go up to my room.
I s'pose.
Hello?
Oh jeez
Wait, what the fuck?
Woah, what the--?
What i- What is this?
What is-- woah
What?
Oh, downstairs?
Oh.
I thought it-
Uh-oh
WhaddoIdo?
Oh.
Hello.
Hi.
Ohh, okay.
Why am I here?
What happened?
What the fuck happened to me?
Ok...
I can't really seeee shit.
*loud crash and broken glass*
AH, FUCK OFF!
Don't do that!
HEY!!
WHO BE THUMPING AROUND THERE?
HUH?
YOU BETTER NOT BE THUMPING UP ON ME.
I'M THE THUMP MASTER.
IMMA THUMP YA BACK.
eugh.
Alrighty then..
WHO'S EVER THERE?-
WHAT ARE YOU DOING HERE TEDDY BEAR?
HUHHHH?
Ghost stuffed teddy bear. Maybe that means I have to put a teddy bear there.
"Death of a Salesman. Some have the courage to live, some have the courage to die."
Uhhh-- I don't know about either of those options.
How 'bout I stay safely in between, not actually do anything with my life.
Eugh
Oh..
Oh.
Oh--
Why?
"The Bridge Builder. The builder lifted his old gray head;
"Good friend, in the path I have come," he said
"There followed after me to-day
"A youth whose feet must pass this way."
"This chasm that has been as naught to me"
"To be-- that fair-haired youth may a pitfall be;"
"He, too, must cross in the twilight dim;"
"Good friend, I am building this bridge for him!"
I don't know what that means.
I don't know why you do that.
I don't know why you have claw hand.
And I--
(Mark Growling) Doon't do that
Don't do that.
Don't do that, buddy boo.
Don't be doing that.
Don't be following me either.
Eugh...
This is horrifying
Alright, moving on.
Moving oooon.
Hello.
Hi.
Who is-- oh good--
More down.
Who would've known that my house was so good and deep.
And biiiig.
I can't see shit.
Even with this flashlight I can't see shit.
Am I even moving?
I am moving.
Eugh
*creepy music in the distance*
I'd rather not-- Ooooooooookay.
Well...
Ooooohhh.
Okay.
Hello
Ah, hello.
It's a familiar painting.
How is you?
Ah, good to see you-
Ohh...
huh
Aww, birdies
Birdies.
No birdies.
Probably all birdies dead.
Are you live?
No, you dead.
Woah.
"Bird suicide in Jatinga, India"
Blah blah
blah blah
blah blah blah blah
"Birds crashing down." ...?
"Go berserk." ...?
"Century-old phenomenon of plummeting to ground during this time of year." ...?
Weird...
Oh!
Oh i-- i-- is this really better?
I-- i-- is that better?
You know what, I'll take it.
For ambiance sake, I'll take it.
"The bird-boy"
"Late one autumn night a-- young queen stood by her window,
gazing upon the silent and deserted meadows gleaming in the moonlight."
"Crying mournfully, the bird circled--
Wow...
I'm not reading all of this
Okay. That was a lot there.
Ther- it was a full story if you don't know about the story, go and look it up.
Uh, you can read it.
That was a lot to read and I don't know why it was all in here
I don't know why in this-- is this room dedicated to birbs (Birds)
(Tape Playing) "It's December 3rd..."
*breathing*
(Tape Playing) "It's December 3rd."
Mark: Yeah?--
(tape Playing) "It's been about a month since Oliver passed and..."
"I still can't help but feel like it was my fault."
"I'd been so immersed in my studies that I neglected to attend any of my son's performances or even spend any time with him at all."
"I let my work become my life,"
"Some part of me feels like there's a sort of a catalyst for my son's suicide."
"My wife has certainly been under a lot of stress lately as well."
"But it feels like she was the only one who understood Oliver."
"I know that Katy is taking this all quite well and,"
"I just hope that Lea's too young to understand what happened." (Tape recording ends)
Mark: Oh...
Oh okay, well that was me.
Aw, and the music stopped.
Okay.
Is that-- is that the son?
Is that who we're talking about over here?
I'm not 100% sure.
And the musi-- ohhh tha-- that must be why that picture is absolutely everywhere.
Eh, okay...
Ok, thank you.
It got eerily quieeeet.. after thaaat.
Ok...
I'm gonna go now.
I'm gonna leeeeeave.
I think that's actually outside.
I was-- uh-- spooped by a noise, a sound, I heard outside.
*door creaks open*
Ah.
Yes.
Good god.
This is dark.
"Oliver went with me to the park today. I wish he would play with me more, but he only read."
"Oliver never talks to me and he only plays with friends from the theater."
"I can't wait until I'm older and I can show him how many friends I have."
"Mom is saying that Oliver won't come home anymore. Mom is crying and I don't see why. I hope I see him soon."
"Mom said that Oliver is in a new home in the sky. Maybe he is flying with the birds."
"Oliver visits me all the time now and he always plays with me. Oliver is the best brother ever."
Well, that's not good-- Am I Lea?
Oh
Thought I saw something.
Oh.
Maybe I did.
Okay.
Am I Lea, or am I someone?
I seem pretty tall for a little--- (Mark gasps)
Hiiiii.
How are you doing?
Oh...
Uhhh...
Let me take a se-zzhh--
Ok, goodbyeeeee.
Sorry you had another appointment, you had to leave.
Th-that's fine.
It fine. Don't worry 'bout me.
I'm just a little girl.
(Mark jams out on the xylophone)
Beautiful music
Great...
Okay...
So, what the hell is happening here?
I gotta admit. It's really intriguing.
Like I am...
Very, very curious about what's going on in this world and why it's all here.
Hello
Hiiiiii.
Hello.
Anybody home?
Please don't say yes.
I'd rather not.
I should've gotten the flashlight, this candle isn't doing--
Woah--
"Lea has been calling more of them."
"More OFTEN, than usual just to talk about random things. It was enjoyable at first, but now I can clearly tell she's upset about something."
"She has been talking about family a lot, saying how important they are."
"She repeated several times that Oliver 'did not want to be forgotten.' That really stuck with me."
She repeated several times that Oliver "did not want to be forgotten." That really stuck with me.
"During our conversation today Lea brought up Oliver multiple times, asking me what he was like and then asking me about his death."
"It was all quite strange because I don't see how she could still hold memories of him when I hardly remember him."
"This is the third day in a roll that Lea has called."
"Today Lea called me and said that she can still see Oliver."
"She called and said that Oliver was with her-- right then, and he wanted to talk to me."
"I hung up because, to be honest, she was freaking me out. Later today though,"
"she called back and acted as though none of that had ever happened."
"I think spending a few days with mom and dad will help her,"
"and if it makes her stop calling me about her dead brother, I'm all for it."
*door creaks* "Lea has been--
*door shuts, Mark gasps*
*door shuts*
Okayyy
Okay.
*Mark's voice strains* "Lea has been missing for more than a week now"
"and all of the interest *pause* she had in Oliver and his suicide has me worried I just don't wanna lose my sister"
Oh...
Okay...
Euuuh.
*door creaks*
Okay...
Euhhh...
I'm gonna go get the flashlight again, because this candle ain't doing jack dick. (You aren't either, Mark.)
Ah, yeah, now I can see. Okay.
So now that-- I think I got everything in here.
Ok. So I think I got everything in all the rooms.
So let's go over here.
*door creaks*
Uh-oh...
That's a deep comforting rum hole.
That's a deep comforting rumble.
Ohh, boy.
Ohhh, boy.
Ohhhh, boy.
Ohhhhh, boy.
Ohhhhhh, boy.
Oh, I can't see shit...
Again.
Is it a maze.
Oh, hello.
What are you?
Oh, lovely.
I love it.
I love to love it.
And love the love that I love for it.
Ah...
Great.
I'm just hoping that if I compi--
Ohhhhhhh, boy.
A birthday cake.
I love that.
Love to love that.
All my love is pouring out through my love...
glands.
Ew... gross.
AHH--
AHFFFFFFffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffff-frick...
Alllllrighty then.
That's how you're gonna play it, huh?
Ok. I'll leave that on just beca--
Naw, I'll turn that off
That's gonna get annoying after a while.
*sighs*
I was gonna do it just to make a landmark for me so I'd know where I've been.
Aw man, I'm gonna get so lost in here.
Aw, jeez
Oh, hello
Hi, bright light.
OH....
Oh, hiii.
Hiiii?
Was that a ghost hand?
Hellooooo.
Lookin' good.
Okay...
Goodbye then...
Just gonna go on my way.
Eugh.
Alright.
*Shrill Toot*
(Mark Gasps)
Who did that?!
WAS THAT SOMETHING OVER THERE?
I didn't see it.
So it didn't happen.
Everybody pretend like that didn't happen.
Nothing's bad, everything's great.
What's over here.
Ohhh, it's interpretive art. Greaaaat. Love it.
Love to love love and love love.
Love it.
Eugh.
Oh, good. I found a way out. Good
Aw, great.
Oh, good.
Goody, goody gum drops, how did that--
Eugh...
Oh.
Oh, no. Well... That's a lot of stairs.
Why?
Ah, jeez, my hands cramping up trying contr-
Oh, shit.
Sorry.
My hand--
That's how sensitive this thing's---
Just slight movements.
I've been-- I've been cramping up trying to keep it steady, but when I freak out like I obviously can't even-- can't even keep a hold of it.
Oh...
Am I just gonna be wondering down this staircase?
And I'm supposed to assume nothing bad is gonna happen to me on the way down.
I'm just gonna be living a happy fun life all the way down to the bottom.
Ohhh yeah sure I believe that.
Ok, now that we've gone down the giant, spiral staircase of nothingness...
Why did we do that?
What is down here?
What a messed up place.
Alrighty then...
Ooooh, what's that on the desk there?
A ticket of some sort...
It's like some sort of ticket.
I can't click on it though, so...
Guess it's nothing...
Ohhhhh, it's to the show...
Ahhhhhhh, what lovele--
-- ly gallery.
Oh, oh no.
Oh no.
Eugh
Eughh.
Eughhh..
Eughhhh...?
Hi!
Okay.
This seems okay.
This seems alright.
Hellov
"Lea and Oliver"
Okay...
Alright.
Oh.
AH. Fucking.
Where am I going?
*gasp* Hi. Hello.
Hi.
Oh, oh good. Great. (knocking on door)
Hello? Hi
Be right with you...
"Now we can play together forever"
OH.
OH. So that's the end.
WOW.
That seemed finished.
Maybe it wasn't finished.
But th-the developers said that it wasn't finished.
But that was still good.
It wasn't exactly a satisfying ending, but...
That was actually really good.
It had me on the edge of my seat. I was waiting for like in the typical indie horror game where it's just one big closing jump scare and then it's gone.
But it's kinda neat just to see it like: "Oh my god, no, I'm trapped! No!,  Fuck, dude!."
And then...
That's it. It's over. So anyway, that was actually really good. I was on the edge of my seat. I mean obviously some problems and some bugs through out the game, but...
It was pretty good. The atmosphere was there. I was terrified.
I was waiting for something to happen. Legitimately I was terrified, and I bet there was probably more jump scares in the maze in there, but I probably didn't get to all of them.
So maybe you can. So if you wanna play it, I'll put a link in the description below.
Thank you everybody so much for watching!
And as always, I will see you; in the next video.
Buh byeeeee.